fiestas de espuma espectáculos de baile
o una tarde en la piscina el gran motor
rainbow es el primer hotel el eje de
cuba que tras cerrar sus puertas por la
pandemia de kobe 19 vuelve a dar la
bienvenida a turistas de todo el mundo
tenemos la bandera raimon en la entrada
es decir en el acto y justamente en una
de las paredes y también en nuestro lo
vi como identificativo de que trabajamos
orientados a la comunidad
una locación una instalación donde la
comunidad se sienta protegida se sienta
representada tras 10 meses de
confinamiento el turismo se reactivó en
juba a mediados de noviembre los
visitantes canadienses han sido los más
ácidos al lugar rodeado de playas
paradisíacas
es algo muy bueno y espero que este
lugar inspira al gobierno cubano para
generar cambios para la comunidad lgbt y
sus derechos espero que esto sea un
cambio positivo para la isla de lan en
cuba un nuevo código de familia que
permitiría el matrimonio igualitario
podría ser sancionado por la asamblea
nacional este mismo año y sometido a
referendo nacional en 2022 sin embargo
la unión entre personas del mismo sexo
es una propuesta que lleva años
estancada pues los estigmas persisten en
la sociedad cubana en la última década
la isla ha logrado grandes avances para
la comunidad lgtb pero su lucha continúa
a pesar del rechazo de grupos
evangélicos y otros sectores de la
sociedad